hmm  [Music]  this isn't funny amber when do you like  to play a game tara  [Laughter]  doors unlocked  all doors locked  doors unlocked  hello  it's happening  three attacks so far do you have a gun  i'm sydney prescott of course i have a  gun  something about this one just feels  different  samantha  i'm i know who you are  i've been through this  a lot  this is your life now which means that  whoever this is is going to keep coming  for you  are you ready  for this  never  oh certain rules to surviving  the attacks were all on people related  to the original killers  whatever his link is to our past  it's pulled us all back here  and i won't sleep until he's in the  ground  sydney  it's an honor  you